Speaker 1: Hey, David, we see more and more
sexual assault allegations and sexual harassment
allegations against candidates, and it seems
to matter less than ever.
Do voters even care about sexual harassment
anymore?
I think that this is an interesting question
for a couple of different reasons.
It does seem as though lately candidates and
other prominent people get hit with allegations
of sexual harassment or sexual assault.
They don't drop out or resign or go into therapy
or whatever.
You know, there's different ways that it's
sometimes handled and they still sort of do
OK.
I mean, Donald Trump is example.
No one accused by, you know, 16 to 48 different
women at different points in time and didn't
drop out and was elected president, period.
There was that special election in Alabama
where Republican Roy Moore, who was accused
of harassing underage women, lost by only
a point and a half in twenty seventeen.
Now a Republican losing by one point five
and in Alabama is a big deal because it's
such a red state.
But it didn't completely knock him out of
the running.
If a couple of things went a little differently,
he still would have won.
Andrew Cuomo, he has been accused of all sorts
of improper touching and a verbal comments
by multiple women.
He has said, at least for now, he's not going
to resign, even if he's not cleared by the
attorney general report.
He's made public appearances with other legislative
leaders, some of whom called for him to resign.
But about half of New Yorkers don't think
he should resign.
That includes 61 percent of Democrats.
It's still currently under the investigation
phase.
But we've seen people resign during investigations
before and it's not clear it's having a major
impact.
Some of the covid mishandling is with the
nursing home scandal we talked about previously.
But he's just still kicking around Matt Gates.
Now, Matt Gates allegedly paid for sex from
underage women for whom he paid to go from
one state to another, which legally counts
as sex trafficking.
Not facing too many calls to resign.
The Republican caucus is basically behind
him.
It's not clear whether it's going to affect
him unless he's actually charged.
And even then, we're going to wait and see.
During the Brett Kavanaugh confirmation hearings
to the Supreme Court, he maintained very high
Republican support.
After Christine Blazey Blazey, Ford testified
Brett Kavanaugh's approval from Republicans
went up, even if I recall correctly.
So there's a couple of different things going
on here.
We sort of knew a lot of people didn't really
care.
But increasingly, it seems as though it's
not playing a role in politics where there
are more people taking the approach of it.
Depends who you talk to, but a lot of Democrats
taking the approach of if Republicans aren't
going to hold them accountable, why are we
going to go crazy?
The Al Franken situation comes to mind where
compared to the things Republicans have been
accused of and just stuck it out.
Al Franken resignation is now seen as premature
by many, given what he was accused of.
An untasteful joke for for tasteless joke.
No, no doubt about it.
But comparatively, you've seen a lot of Democrats
say, hey, let's not go crazy because they're
not doing anything about these allegations
on their side.
I think Republican voters genuinely don't
care.
They have taken a sort of greater good mentality
of, yeah, even if we're evangelical Christians,
we'll still elect the guy with the multiple
wives and the cheating and the divorce and
the mistresses and whatever, because Democrats
are just worse in general and they support
abortion and whatever.
So they justify it that way.
So I think that while individuals in their
lives care about sexual harassment and sexual
assault, I think politically it is less of
a successful or effective hatchet to end someone's
career.
And that's a result both of some aspects from
the right and some aspects from the left,
although the left has been far more consistent
when it came to Al Franken, Anthony Weiner
in just abandoning the accused people, I think
some sort of realpolitik type, pragmatic perspective
lately is making even some on the left reconsider
whether we should just leave the sexual harassment
to that's the personal life of the individual
and at least claim that it has nothing to
do with their actions as an elected official